A yarn balance or scale
is a useful tool to identify the yards per
pound of yarn, maybe mistery
yarn or a skein of yarn.
By knowing the yards per pound,
you can more easily compare the weights
of yarn, this tool is available from many
sources specializing in weaving yarn.
They're available for weighing,
yarn in both metric and imperial units.
Set up, the scale on a level surface.
Set the metal pins into the slots
on each side of the box.
Now cut a strand of yarn and hang it over
the notched edge of the scale
with the yarn hanging freely.
Initially, the scale will hang downward
from the weight of the yarn.
Use a pair of scissors and carefully start
trimming both ends of the yarn strand
in about half-inch increments
until the scale is level.
Remove the strand of yarn and then measure
it, just stretch it just slightly.
And multiply the inch measurement by 100
to determine the yards per pound.
In this example, it measures 9.5 inches times 100
this yarn and would be approximately
950 per pound.
Now, here's another tip
to determine the amount of yarn remaining
on a cone or a ball of yarn,
weigh the cone on a kitchen or
postal scale, a digital scale,
subtract about an ounce
for the paper cone.
Divide by 16, the yards per pound,
determined by the yard balance,
16 ounces equals one pound.
To find the number of yards remaining,
multiply the answer by the number
of ounces of yarn remaining.
Here's an example,
using the yarn balance,
we determined that this yarn is
approximately 950 yards
per pound.950 divided by 16
equals 59 yards per ounce.
The remaining yarn weighs
6.5 ounces.
Do the math and this little ball has about
yards remaining.